new homework assignment by definition
people don't want to do homework I'm not
saying this is a good thing I'm just
saying it's a homework assignment
everyone should watch this movie to
truly appreciate pacing I like it that
way where you should try diet coke so
you truly appreciate regular coke they
sing holy [ __ ]
Aloha so Aloha is written and directed
by the director of Jerry Maguire almost
famous good movies that you've seen
you're like that dudes a good director
right this is proof positive that a
talented director will not always make a
good movie I don't even know where to
start with this movie so I'm gonna start
with the main characters Bradley
Cooper's kind of a burnout in the
military and Emma Stone's is
up-and-comer she's really jacked up
she's really energetic she's really
optimistic almost to a stupid degree
you're like you can't really believe
that there's no way in any case now this
movie's gonna force these two to have a
romance together because what needs to
happen you buy it about as much as you
think you're going to seriously this is
one of those find yourself romantic
awkward comedies so the two main
characters have to have chemistry it's
not their I love Emma Stone I love
Bradley Cooper together I guess they
just don't work in the same way I love
cheeseburgers and ice cream I guess you
just shouldn't blend them together
separately beautiful their entire
relationship in this movie reminded me
of screech and Lisa turtle from Saved by
the Bell
literally the same thing screeches
hyperactive he's kind of an idiot he
just wants nothing more than to please
Lisa Lisa sees this and proceeds to act
like a [ __ ] to him because so
basically Bradley Cooper is acting like
a teenage girl in this movie that's
where we are a lot of these lines in the
tree I hate it when trailers do this
they show you lines you look okay it's
just pulled from the movie right then
you watch the movie you're like nope
that line was delivered just so you
could have it in the trailer like that
scene in the trailer where Bill Murray
has this great monologue about life and
how it's just this vibrant thing that's
gonna steamroll you with a wicked sense
of humor and whom not careful it's gonna
get you nose like that's gonna be a
great party's gonna be like Bill
Murray's gonna play this billionaire
with a heart of gold you're not gonna
know he has a heart of gold until he
says that monologue and it's all gonna
make sense no literally what happens is
everyone's hanging out at a party it
cuts over to Bill Murray and this hot
chick who has no lines in the movie
looks to him and she goes what's life
and then he has the monologue when the
monologues done that scene is done it
didn't flow it was awkward it was out of
place and that's not the only place
something like that happens in this
movie this entire movie feels like
that's like a Frankenstein of scenes
that don't really work together I've
been Bradley Cooper in the trailers
ordering a coffee and he was like hey
I'll take a double she's like hey sir
I'm so jacked for today he's like make
that in trouble that scene exists
exactly how the scene exists in the
trailer it's like it's just there to be
in the trailer really awkwardly chopped
together I'm not gonna say this movie
doesn't have moments
heart that make you step back and you're
like alright that was done well there
are a couple of scenes especially when
the movies wrapping up you're like okay
why didn't you hit these notes earlier
on in the movie you would be winning me
over if I felt like there was you know a
movie to go but the movies over man I
checked out a long time ago and if
you've seen the movie you know who I'm
talking about if you haven't seen the
movie good for you
there is a character in this movie that
Bradley Cooper should have had more
screen time with should have built a
bigger relationship with didn't happen
whatsoever and it's just a complete
waste guys in the end Aloha is a wreck
it's a mess there are moments when it
gleams through and you can almost see
where the vision was going but it's
buried under this convoluted a story
that tries to be more clever than it
actually ends up being the characters
didn't work well together the actors
just didn't have chemistry and in the
end you walk out knowing not thinking
not suspecting but knowing that you're
really never gonna watch this movie
again because you're not gonna remember
Aloha I'm t-minus one day ya already
forgot all right guys so we're gonna go
negative on this I don't like being too
negative but let's go there what is the
movie with the shittiest chemistry among
actors for you don't say Twilight that's
cheating don't say Fifty Shades you gray
that's cheating - whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you wanna see more click right here to
say more
you